now there are a few more cowardly actors
in modern American politics than Mitt
Romney now let me explain now back in
the 2012 Presidential Republican primary
Senator Mike Lee went out on a limb and
he became the first member of the Tea
Party caucus to support Mitt Romney's
bid for the nomination
now to return the favor Romney is now
the only GOP senator who has an endorsed
Lee's re-election citing his
relationship with Lee's opponent
independent candidate and professional
grifter Evan McMullen now what does that
holdout produced well a flurry of puff
pieces
Evan McMullen is asking voters from both
parties to join his Insurgent campaign
to win a senate seat as an independent
from Utah our democracy is at Great risk
right now and we will decide as a nation
over the next two cycles this cycle and
the next whether we still are a
democracy or whether we're going to head
down a road towards authoritarianism
see in a Maverick right but
with Plucky underdog not the guy who's
Wayward 2016 independent bid resulted in
670
000 bucks in unpaid bills
McMullen says he understands the
challenge but urges voters to see that
his Allegiance is to Utah not a
political party I'm not running to be a
bootlegger for the leader of any party
or the you know or or a president of any
party I will work with anybody to get
things done for our state and our
country
I was expecting right there Jeff seleni
and McMuffin to just go full spooning
Senator Lee was willing to even
sacrifice our Constitution and his oath
to it in order for him and his allies
Donald Trump and and his other political
allies to hold on to power would you go
as far as saying he violated his oath of
office he violated the Constitution he
violated the law
I think he violated his oath certainly
and I I think he violated the
Constitution if your number one issue is
defending democracy you won't be able to
build a coalition with those Republican
Senators
I don't even know who that person is
that anchor but enjoy the fruits of your
cowardice mittens joining me now is Newt
Gingrich former Speaker of the House Fox
News contributor
Newt um look I supported Romney in 2012.
I mean I've I've known Romney going back
to the early 2000s I've always liked him
personally but there this Trump
derangement Syndrome has really revealed
a lot about the establishment and what
they really stood for all along has it
not
well it's particularly dumb for a
Republican senator to not be endorsing a
Republican senator there's no question
but that McMullen is going to vote with
the Democrats I mean all this nonsense
about being independent that's just
baloney the way the Senate and the house
work you ultimately end up with a party
Bernie Sanders is technically an
independent however he meets with the
Democrats that's a fact Angus King of
Maine is technically an independent
however he meets with the Democrats if
McMullen wins is a vote for Schumer and
a vote for Biden it's that simple that
straightforward and why Romney would
vote or fail to pursue helping his
colleague keep a republican majority
which is whether they're drifting now
towards a majority and Utah be one of
those great surprises if we lost it
furthermore Senator Lee is a remarkable
constitutional scholar a solid
conservative and somebody who by any
reasonable standard has earned the
support of every Republican in the
country so I'm puzzled by Romney's
confusion about his own future
well speaking of failures of the
Democrats and Republicans who don't seem
to understand how important they are for
the country and to recognize new we just
learned late today that the ACT test
scores those are tests that kids take to
get into college they dropped to the
lowest level in 30 years in the pandemic
slide that is a total indictment as a
nod of democrat Governors Mayors
teachers unions all across the country
who kept these schools closed uh at this
point tantamount to child abuse yet we
still have Republicans like Romney
trying to keep the status quo going
look the fact is the greatest threat to
American long-term National Security is
the collapse of our education system uh
the Department of Education under Biden
is looking at very radical positions on
transgenderism on imposing on kids all
sorts of things that don't relate to
learning they don't teach you how to do
math they don't teach you how to read or
write but they have all these strange
weird ideas that they're trying to
impose and the fact is this is really a
deep National Security crisis it goes
all the way back to President Reagan who
issued a report in 1983 called a nation
at risk that said if a foreign power did
to our children what the schools are
doing we would consider an act of war
and I think we have to recognize the
teachers unions have told out totally
their results are disastrous it's excuse
me they're very expensive and yet
they're not producing and nobody wants
to go out and have the kind of reforms
we need in some states Florida Arizona
you begin to see real change putting
parents back in charge and I think
that's frankly going to be the future to
have what Betsy DeVos called education
Freedom more than just school choice but
a freedom to find out how your child
learns and whether it's an
apprenticeship or it's an online or it's
in a charter school or under whatever
circumstance and that is I think going
to be one of the biggest fights for our
survival as a country fantastic new
great to see you thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else